When you have a child, everything will
change. Your priorities will change. The
urgency of situations will change.
You'll have to take precedent for your
child over other things. I think a lot
of people sort of fail to understand
that. It comes with growth and maturity.
So, you need a few years to sort of
adapt to marriage life. Oh, when we
ready to have kids? You're never ready
to have kids. You're never ready to have
kids. When you have kids, Allah puts
everything in place. You know, there's a
lot of things that men are very ignorant
about when it comes to having a baby.
And so, they really do need to prepare
for that because you shouldn't place all
the responsibilities on the woman. The
man will become less attracted to his
wife after she's given birth. The effort
you made if you knew one another before
marriage, don't stop that even after
having kids. Like we mentioned,
postnatal depression, postnatal
psychosis. Now, postnatal psychosis
brings on symptoms that many people
think that woman is now possessed. Yeah?
This is a big one in our This is big one
in our community. Not
Because a lot of men don't like when
their woman puts the child before them.
I don't know why they have a problem
with that. But a lot of
men change. He's lonely. He's like, "But
she said this. And how could she say
that, bro?" No, I'm The guy you look at
this grown man who was like a tank. He
would beat up four guys. And he's
crumbled. When your wife is telling you
something about your child, and she's
and she's going against the people who
are giving you advice, I would say
listen to her.
100%. I know a lot of people who where
the man continues to feel like a ghost
in his own house. He's done everything
he can to provide, to be there for his
wife and the kids, right? And he still
feels neglected. It's been 2 3 years,
maybe even more. And the wife's still
not giving him attention. And sometimes
even when she mentions, "By the way, I'm
pregnant." Please make sure your
reaction is not Alhamdulillah.
Not that there's nothing wrong with it,
but you know it's like, "Oh, okay." Are
you sure? Are you sure?
Okay, I need to go. They go a bit weird
on the wife. Oh, she's acting different.
She's doing this. She's doing that. The
thing is this is like they don't even
understand what she's going through.
Yeah. There is a sense of freedom in not
having a child. If you want to enjoy
freedom, then you shouldn't get married.
You shouldn't No, no. You can have You
can have freedom in a marriage.
Islamnet is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway.
And they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqa jariya
for you because every person that comes
a step closer to Allah through your
donation, you will inshallah be reaping
the reward. Click the link and donate
what you can. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers and
sisters and dear fans. Hope you guys are
well, inshallah. Welcome to another
episode of The Bitter Truth Show. Before
I start, I want to praise Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, the most merciful,
the most just. All praises, glory, and
gratitude belong to him. If you guys
want to be a part of the show, be a
participant, a guest, you can please
apply on the
You'll probably see it on the screen.
thebittertruthshow@gmail.com.
Wherever you are, inshallah,
whatever background, you can come and
have your input. Today's topic is going
to be something interesting in the sense
where
where when do you believe So, the
question be out there is that when do
you guys believe that newlywed couples
should have kids? That's the topic at
hand.
I have my own take on it, but I'll come
to that later.
But yeah, so we have some new guests.
We've got brother Safdar, who's regular.
May Allah bless him, inshallah. He's
been coming here with his wife. And now
he's coming here today himself. May
Allah bless him. He's
helping me He's going to help me on a
diet plan, but he's I've sent him my
weight, but I need to send him a few
more details here. I'm a bit late.
It's been a year. It's been It's been a
year.
And we've got a new brother, inshallah.
Your name is?
Sorry, yeah. My name is Armaan.
I teach at with us.com. And I also own a
registered charity, akromaid.org.
So, yeah.
That's on the side, to be honest. Yeah.
That's good, man. May Allah bless him,
inshallah. We've got brother Matthew,
who's a regular. No introduction needed.
Alhamdulillah.
Mehdi, how old are you? I'm 25. 25.
Okay, masha Allah. 25.
Good. Alhamdulillah. We've got sister
Anamta, who is a regular.
We've got sister Farzana,
who is also a regular. And we've got a
new sister, sister
Anum? Anum.
A N U? A M U N. So, Amun. Yes. A M U N.
Sister Amun, may Allah bless her,
inshallah. So, yeah. Let's Let's get
straight into it, inshallah.
So,
obviously we've got people who are
married here. We've got people who are
divorced here. We've got single
brothers. Are you married? I'm I'm
divorced. Oh, you're divorced. Okay, no
problem. Alhamdulillah. Yeah. People who
have been divorced. So, in a nutshell,
let's open the topic at hand, inshallah.
When do you guys believe
couples should have kids? Like when
should they plan to have kids? You know?
Sister, I want Let's start with sister
Farzana, inshallah.
If it's Yeah, cuz I think you you you
Tell us a bit about what you do. Okay.
So, I'm a relationship coach and a
therapist. So, there's few modalities I
use. Okay.
work with them, sisters. Um
So, my take on that is it depends on the
couple themselves. Okay. But at the same
time, saying that,
it's cuz obviously the way it depends on
the way the marriage came together and
how it all happened. But I would say
about 2 years it takes to kind of get to
know each other.
going to say that, yeah. Get your
footings and
how it depends on the situa- situation.
But ideally, I believe so. My opinion is
2 years. Give it 2 years and then
you know, you have to learn on how to
bring up a child in the first place cuz
it's obvious most people would have gone
into a marriage learning about how to
live with someone. Yeah. And
be a married couple.
But
Yeah, so that's what I was saying. I
I've heard 2 years a lot of places, but
I don't know. Does anyone disagree? Is
that Yeah. Let me say.
I think yeah, like first year I should
be knowing each other when you get
married. About knowing getting their
relationship strong. So, a lot of people
what they do when they get married as
soon as there's like a mission for them
to have kids because maybe they get
married too late. And they're thinking
the first thing they should do is have
kids. No, you need to have connection
with your wife. So, first year should
know start knowing each other, then plan
having kids. So, that'll be like another
9 months having kids. And the thing is
like the connection with your wife is
very, very important because after
pregnancy, when she has a baby, you need
to know there's a lot of things comes
with the pregnancy as well because you
got postnatal depression, all sorts of
things. But because if you don't know
your wife,
you don't know she's having these
problems. So, I think yeah, like
2 years, like first year knowing each
other, then after that plan to have a
baby.
So, both of you are in a strong position
to look after the baby and connect with
the baby and connect as a family. So,
yeah. Alhamdulillah. I've got a
4-year-old at the moment.
And
basically I got married. And then my
first three things was
do I have enough resources to start a
family?
And then the other thing was my grand my
parents, they're really old. And I've
seen
I never saw my grandparents. So, I
wanted my child to
have that love of a grandparent.
And then the third thing was
I'm very sporty. And I just wanted to be
when he's at the age of playing sports,
I wanted to be competitive with him. So,
those were the things that I looked at
first. But then now looking back on it,
I think that the connection between me
and my wife was much more important
because after giving birth,
her negativity towards me, for example,
had an impact on how he perceived me as
well. And that and how he perceived
marriage as well. And that's something
that I didn't think about beforehand.
And that's definitely something I would
reconsider next time I
had a child, to be honest. So,
I agree with Farzana's point as well
with um
when you have a kid, everything changes,
right? So, 2 years I think would be
appropriate. Depends on the
circumstance. But I think the biggest
thing along with having a connection
with your wife is to sort of understand
your priorities will change. When you
first get married, there's a honeymoon
phase. Go on holidays. You're sort of
spending on each other. When you have a
child, everything will change. Your
priorities will change. The urgency of
situations will change. You'll have to
take precedent for your child over other
things. I think a lot of people sort of
fail to understand that. It comes with
growth and maturity. So, you need a few
years to sort of adapt to marriage life.
Understand that, you know, you're saving
for a a kid to eventually come along.
And then everything will sort of fall
into place after that. So, a few years
is probably best appropriate, I think.
Thing is I I just want to say one thing
and that everyone goes like lot of
people what they say is do is Oh, when
we ready to have kids? You're never
ready to have kids. You're never ready
to have kids. When you have kids, Allah
puts everything in place. Like when I
had my kids, alhamdulillah, everything
just worked out perfectly. And when I
was holding my daughter for the first
time, I thought, "How am I going to look
after her?" Just everything just works
out. So, you never It happens when it
happens. You're just ready for it. You
know what I mean? You're ready to take
that role as a father. And the mother is
already ready to take that role as a
mother. So, don't ever like plan things
that are, you know, we we going to have
kids when we
save certain amount of money or buy this
house or anything like that. The thing
is is just having a family is a big, big
blessing that we should focus on and
support and promote for other brothers
and sisters to start that off and do it
in the right way.
So, I'm a midwife.
And I think it just comes down to if you
both know what your priorities are and
if you both are ready for it, especially
in terms of the man, if he is capable of
doing,
you know, his duties as a father
and helping her out because when she's
done, she will be
um
she she could be sick. She could again,
postnatal depression. She could have
some healing to do. So, you know, you
just both have to have that conversation
beforehand. It's almost like before
you're getting married, you have to have
serious talks before you get married. In
the same way as when you're having a
baby, you have to really think of all
different situations you could be placed
in
and prepare yourselves for that. But
again, I think it also comes down to
when you're ready. It doesn't have to be
2 years. Some women really do want to be
mothers and they really want to get
that, you know, the ball rolling. And I
think it's up to, you know, to her and
the man when they're ready and it
shouldn't be time limited. When is the
woman ready then?
Well, again, I told you like some women,
they, you know, yearn to be mothers and
as soon as they get that opportunity,
they want to get it started. So,
it's, you know, she will know when she's
ready and it's just I would say it's
more on the man to prepare himself
because, you know, there's a lot of
things that men are very ignorant about
when it comes to having a baby and so
they really do need to prepare for that
because, you shouldn't place all the
responsibilities on the woman. Um, I
know for my culture, um, you know, the
men always expect the women to do most
of the mothering and most of the
parenting, but for your child to have
the best of, um, upbringing, I would say
the man has to also prepare himself to,
you know, do his bidding and do his
part. Sorry, sister. I want to ask you,
you're a midwife. Um, so the thing is,
do you think in most of the cultures a
lot of men don't know about postnatal
depression?
Yeah, many things as well, not just
postnatal depression. There's a lot of
complications that can happen. Sister,
sorry. Can you get the mic a bit closer
so people can hear clearly? Cuz
Mashallah, you've got some very vital
points that brothers should hear. Um,
you know, there's a lot of
complications, not just postnatal
depression. There's psychosis, there's,
uh, you know, health issues. Again,
things could go seriously wrong during
birth. Um, even sometimes death. And so
the man really, really has to think
about these things. Um, Has to be
prepared for them things before
Absolutely. There's a lot of preparation
that goes into it and you can't just go
and do anything.
my personal point that we don't talk
about this situation a lot.
Yeah. The thing is we think that our our
baby's going to born and that's it and
we don't realize what the woman goes
through through all these things and
that that she has to go through. And I
think in our community, we need to talk
about these situations a lot. Yeah.
Because, um, I've I've known a lot of,
uh, brothers that have, um, that have
babies and stuff and they go a bit weird
on their wife as she's acting different,
she's doing this, she's doing that. The
thing is this is like they don't even
understand what she's going through.
Yeah. So, um, this is a thing we need to
talk about a lot. I personally believe
that.
With psychosis, it's a spectrum. You
know, this is something that's very
possible in happening. Um, and again,
like the man could think it's on her and
this is how she's acting out or how
she's behaving, um, but it's not. There
is a thing called psychosis which you
have to look out for and you have to
help your wife with and also recognize
it as well. Also recognizing postnatal
depression. You know, it that that's
also a spectrum. It's not just, uh,
you know, seeing her being upset or
crying. It could really be a mental
struggle and she won't talk to you about
it, but it's on you as a husband to
realize and see the signs.
But this is why I say like the
connection is very, very important. If
you don't know
that you don't have that connection with
your wife, you won't be able to read
her.
Um, that's the whole thing and that
that's why I say that connection with
your wife is very important because my
wife had postnatal depression
and I picked up on it straight away. So,
I tried to get the right help for her
and she used to like had had bad
thoughts and all sorts of things, but it
was my job being there for her that
time. She didn't want anyone else. I was
there for her and and this is like
that's why I say having kids, you need
to have that connection with your wife
first to have that understanding if
she's going through something bad or
you're going through something bad, you
know, you can understand each other's
body language. Yeah. It's very, very
important because sometimes we don't
talk about things. Sometimes we're doing
something wrong, but we don't even know
that we're doing something wrong. So,
it's your job for your partner to pick
that up. So, that's that's why it's
important for the man to mature Yes.
and understand his sort of, uh,
responsibilities as a husband and a
father before he just sort of even wants
to get married, to be honest with you.
The big problem I've been seeing quite a
lot is the man will become less
attracted to his wife
after she's given birth. It's a very
common issue that I've been Yeah. So,
obviously when a woman gives birth, like
things will change about her. She might
gain weight, she might lose weight and a
man a lot of men, they'll sort of fall
into that category where I'll like she's
not attracted to her, I don't feel
attracted to her anymore. Some men won't
even sleep in the same room as her
anymore and expect her to sort of deal
with it. Yeah, I've seen a lot of cases
personally. totally opposite, uh,
reaction because she was more attracted
to me because she was mother of my kids
now. So, that kind of brought her even
more close to me. So, the thing is,
yeah, I don't know. I've I've heard few
stories, but I think that's kind of
backward mindset. But, um, personally,
if a woman who carries your child, you
have a child with and what she goes
through, uh, giving birth to that child,
you have more love for her.
Because we you see what she goes
through. Yeah, it it is. I mean like
I'll be honest with you. I've I've had
brothers here, we've had a discussion
about this.
Um, I don't know if you had a whole
topic on it about being there when she's
giving birth, etc. Obviously there were
some brothers I don't want to mention
who were like, you know, and I
understand. I understand for those who
don't want to be there. There is I'm
talking about those who are balancing
the sense where they're like, "Listen,
um, it can
affect my, um,
connection with intimately." Do you get
it? And that's that's valid. That is
valid. I have to be honest, that is
valid, uh, because you're seeing that it
can be graphic for some people. For for
some men if they're like, "You know
what? I do understandable." But this
doesn't necessarily For example, I've
been like my my two daughters,
like all three of them, I've been there
to all of them. Yeah, and it doesn't
necessarily mean you have to see
everything that's happening. Do you get
what I'm trying to say? You can be
behind the bed, etc. Yeah, yeah. I I
personally was a moving moment for me
because it was I'll be honest with you
like it's
to me it might sound strange, but my
last, um, when I had the new baby, um,
when she was born, the first thing was
weird. The first thing that came to my
mind was
and this might sound a little bit crazy,
but it was like, "I understand why
people end up in hellfire." And you
might be like, "What's that got to do
with anything?"
When I looked at the whole
the the the the whole birth happening,
etc., I was like, "How could anybody
know this process? It's a miracle." It
is. I don't believe. I was like, "Bro,
you know what I said? I said, 'I don't
care who it is.
My close family members who do not
believe persistently, I just had this
thing in my heart where I was like, 'You
know what? You Whoever it is for that
matter, you deserve hellfire.' Why?
Because for you to see this miraculous
thing happen in front of your eyes and
this baby is born, yeah, and you don't
believe?
I don't know. That was to me personally.
It was just But before that, it was just
an a moment It just It really makes you
It gets you emotional. And as men, we
need to accept that, you know? For the
brothers who are in the red pill like,
"Oh,
sorry, we don't follow your nonsense and
your metric that you're actually with
discussing metric. We follow the Sunnah,
alhamdulillah." And again, I accept, uh,
fully men who don't want to be there.
It's totally valid. But for men
who have this little boy syndrome of
"I'm the man and I'm going to be there."
Uh, you got a lot of growing up to do.
Um, but let's come back to the topic.
Maybe we should have a whole topic on
that issue because to educate men
We should have a whole topic, babe, just
on that topic because a lot of men are
ignorant, uh, about it.
But there's a verse we want to talk
about because we were talking about uh,
poverty. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says in
the Quran,
"So, uh, it's the chapter 17 verse 28.
Uh, Surah Isra. Uh, but if you must turn
them down because you lack the means of,
uh,
lacks to give while hoping to receive
your Lord's Lord's bounty, then at least
give them a kind word." So, it's talking
about the relatives.
"And do not be so tightfisted for you
will be blameworthy." So, um, don't be
stingy. Uh, nor so open. So, don't be
extra charitable where you're left with
nothing. So, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
saying be balanced. Now, I'm going to be
telling you why I'm mentioning this.
It says, "Surely your Lord gives
abundance, uh, your Lord gives
abundance, um, or limited provision to
whoever he wills. He is certainly all
aware, all seeing,
uh, of his servants. Do you not kill
your children
for the fear of poverty. We provide
Sometimes people obviously we're not in
the time of the the the the before Islam
came, the Mushrikin used to kill their
daughters. Uh, there's a lot of things
connected if you read the tafsir.
Sometimes it's the um, you need to
understand as men we have over our
womenfolk. Yeah. Even if you're giving
your daughter in hand to get married,
there's that
inside you. We are men. That's how we're
created. Do you get what I'm trying to
say? The Mushrikin used to kill their
daughters. One of those reasons was that
because if we go to war and they take
our females and they're going to do
whatever,
dishonor kind of attitude even though
it's not it's not their fault. So, they
used to do this kind of stuff. But also
people used to kill their children
because of poverty. Allah's telling you
and this issue here,
if you think about it, it's a matter of
tawhid.
How could you think, "Okay, I'm not
going to have kids cuz I can't provide
for them." Who the hell said you provide
for them? Yeah. Keep yourself Who said
this attitude Look, I understand
that we have to work as men, etc. And
then there are single mothers who have
to be the father and the mother. But who
has given you this impression as if you
are the sole provider? You are not. So,
meaning the following and I've seen many
brothers, bro. Wallahi, there's a
brother that I know who's got up to five
kids. He goes, "Bro, anytime I would
have a child, a blessing comes in my
life, bro." And he was specifically
saying his daughters. I don't know why.
Yeah. But he goes, "Bro, I would look
out to my income and my outgoings. He
goes, 'It doesn't add up.'" He goes,
"I'm looking at my income and my
outgoing is more, but I'm just It's just
just flowing. So, the point is Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala is the one that
blesses. When it comes to this issue of
"Well, I'm poor." But etc.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala will enrich.
Now, coming to the issue of having kids
at 2 years like you guys were talking
about it.
I think it's very important as well to
understand that men are in check. I
think a lot of sisters need to maybe
educate their husbands about this issue
because, um, you know, it's easy to be a
father, it's easy to be a mother. And
like my mom says, "Not every mother that
gives birth becomes a mother." Uh, for
that matter and the same uh, the father
in in that sense. So, the reason I'm
trying to brought up this topic is
because we are living in different
dynamics.
We
we can come across somebody who's got a
full beard, every second word is
alhamdulillah, subhanallah, la ilaha
illallah and he's got a miswak in his
mouth every time and he's got Quran
under under his left arm and he's got a
phone, but you don't know who you're
marrying. The reason I wanted to put the
bar of two years, I don't know what you
guys reason is is that the person you're
marrying could be an absolute Iblis.
Like that would and and and now the
issue is when you're married, you have a
connection, a beautiful connection
to this Iblis, yeah. So, the point is
this, yeah.
So, it's it's it's a blessing like for
example, I don't think you would you you
would divorce. I don't think you would
ever regret having your child. Never
ever alhamdulillah. I know many brothers
never they would say I would marry the
same Iblis just for this beautiful
daughter because he's they're a
blessing.
But in today's time we live in
uncertainty and some people are they got
so many issues going on, bro. And I
personally I've been like been told and
many people have told me that the
two-year mark is where you would know
what somebody's about. So, that's the
angle that I'm coming from. Like would
you not agree that that two-year mark is
fundamental because to protect yourself
in that sense and because once it's it's
devastating. I know brothers who are in
sisters I've heard of stories as well,
of course with men who are careless who
don't even look after their children.
But I've heard of brothers in situations
where they are married to very very evil
woman and now they can't even see their
kids by the way
man's perspective cuz from man's
perspective in in the society that we're
living in, women have a lot of powers
that's given to them, yeah. And they're
abusing those powers by the way. Now we
have brothers that I know, some of them
like I've heard stories of suicide.
They cannot see their kids. So, I
specifically say to men because of that
because not seeing your child is
devastating, bro. It's it's it can
a man a man. So, would you guys
agree from that perspective that we
should have a good two years that's
where I was coming from. But sister
Anamta? I think having the two-year mark
is very vital. Firstly because
communication is key in a relationship.
I feel like especially with you know
people that have arranged marriages
there's that kind of distance in being
comfortable talking to your partner and
having that two-year mark where you know
you travel together, you spending time
together builds that kind of um
comfortable um
aspect in your marriage and then with
that aspect you're able to talk to your
partner and within those two years there
can be a million things you can talk
about, you know. Um that's whether
that's having a baby and when you talk
about you know family when you have
family planning
and you're talking about having a baby,
you can talk about arising issues that
there are within society and you know
just in relationships in general as
well. So, with that with that building
that communication is very vital as well
because then I believe within that two
years you know your partner and the
family that you come into it takes
effort from both sides, not just the
woman, not just the man. I feel like
it's an effort from both sides because
ideally you're both um
you know going into each other's
families, you're meeting each other's
parents, you're meeting each other's
siblings, etc. So, I think that two-year
mark is very vital in order to build
your communication with one another so
you can talk to one another comfortably.
I think we can all agree that sort of
the question of when to have kids is so
situational, isn't it? It's sort of
Exactly, yeah. The reason I said two
years is cuz for me personally I know
I'll have that connection with my wife
by then. We'll have the honeymoon, we'll
go on holidays and stuff. I'll know I
want to settle down by you know a
certain age. That's a target for me as
well cuz if I'm not ready for in two
years after marriage, when will I be
ready? I'll keep pushing the age higher
and higher. So, that's that's why I said
two years essentially. I think it's a
good mark to have. Would you guys say to
say two years is something we can't
generalize it in the sense I believe
it's a safe zone. I think it's safe. Two
two two years is a safe zone.
The only issue we would have if I'm not
mistaken is that okay is there any
matter that two years is a
yeah? Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, I would say
the only issue we have is you need to
understand the sisters um
biologically their time is ticking when
it comes to a certain age. This is a
reality, okay?
Which maybe we can if there's a
difference of opinion on this matter,
but again I understand with Allah
subhana wa ta'ala all things are
possible. We're just talking about tying
our camel. The reason I'm saying that is
cuz there might be a sister in her 30s
or late 30s cuz there are statistics
that show that her chances of conceiving
do dramatically fall. Again, in Allah's
hands all things are possible. You can
be 40, 45 Allah subhana wa ta'ala will
lose it will
We have no we can't say nothing about
that. But if that sister who's let's say
she's in 34, 35 years old, she marries a
a brother who's maybe I don't know in
his
35, 40 cuz he can have kids till he's
70, 80. Now she's like okay look, I
don't want to wait two years.
I was coming from that angle. This is
the first time I've heard before
misunderstanding. But you can correct me
still if there's any like I I didn't
mean it in that way. But again it's a
reality which I have to stick to the
reality which is the the biological
clock for a woman it's more limited than
a man's. Scientifically. Scientifically
but with Allah subhana wa ta'ala all
things are possible. I actually
disagree. Please, sister. Um I've had
women who were 55 years old having
babies. So, the biological clock it's
a generalization of women and it is a
thing. It definitely is a thing. You
can't have a baby past 60. I mean if
Allah's blessed you with that then
alhamdulillah. But
you know the biological clock after 33
years old, you're just called geriatric.
Um it's not
It just means your um
you know you're mature. Yeah, I
like your uterus if you really want to
get into it, your female reproductive
system is a lot more aged. So, you're a
lot more high risk. That's all it means,
but you are still in your childbearing
years. Okay, so we we do agree that look
if Allah wills it for actually said if
you're a midwife 50 years old, 100%. But
exceptions do not make the rule. What
I'm saying generally what I mean by this
by the way I'm not getting into the
whole biological. I'm saying a sister
who's in her late 30s or mid-30s who
want who who marries a guy and that guy
says listen
I want minimum two, three years. To her
that's three years. She's thinking I'm
34, I'm going to be 37. I'm talking from
those dynamics just to give clarity. I'm
not trying to bring the whole thing of
the biological thing. I'm saying
what would you say to that sister cuz
sister is going to be like I don't want
to wait. I've been waiting 30 like this
many years and now you're telling me to
wait another two, three years. How would
we find a middle path because to her
those two, three years can be vital. For
him he's thinking look, I don't know
you. I want to get to know you. I don't
know who you are. Do you get what I'm
saying? How would we balance that?
That's where I'm coming from cuz we've
agreed about the two-year mark. But now
we're dealing with a sister who has a
right for a child, but now the guy is
like well no I want to get to know you.
I want to go holiday. She's like I don't
want holidays. I want kids. So I think I
think she should wait. I think again it
goes back to being prepared. Both sides
should be prepared. She may want to rush
it and this is why I made the point of
this whole biological clock thing it
shouldn't really be on women's minds. I
know it naturally will be. Isn't it
statistically What I'm trying to say is
that women should really have faith in
themselves and have faith in Allah that
you know that risk will happen for them.
Um and they shouldn't have this clock
over their heads really cuz honestly
you've got like if you're 33 years old
or if you're in your 30s you still got a
good 10, 15 years of having a baby. So,
if your you know your partner is saying
let's wait two, three years you
shouldn't feel this clock like at all.
You should just you know
think about things in life.
I'll leave it to the sister. No, no it's
all right. It's all right. So, just to
interrupt this statistically,
scientifically as well women do have a
biological clock. I understand what
you're saying with women shouldn't
think about it to the point where you
know they want to have kids ASAP. I
understand that. But for example, I've
got um
I've got a friend who's had a kid at the
age of like I think it was 40 or
something. I can't remember. And their
baby came out with like a lot of issues,
genetic problems. Exactly. So, that's
that's why women tend to want to have
children at a younger age cuz they know
they have that biological clock. So, I
think it's important to take both
accounts.
Sort of both cases. So, you shouldn't
rush into it, but you shouldn't delay it
to the point where your kids going to be
at a risk.
Yeah, but the thing is it's better to be
safe than sorry, you know what I mean?
So, where the thing is that if a woman
is saying that I've got that much time I
want to rush, but that could cause more
problems. Then Especially in the long
term as well when you have kids actually
emotionally. Yeah, if you're going for
two years then surely you can make it
more efficient and then work harder with
each other to communicate better and
learn about each other in a quicker span
of time. If that's your goal at the end
of the day.
I think I'm going to jump in here.
I think the answer to your question is
that this should have been a discussion
that they should have had prior to
getting married cuz
um True. You have to discuss these
things cuz you can't just jump into a
marriage and then say okay, we'll
discuss this later. Cuz a lot of times
um when a proposal comes the individual
might have been in a place where they've
been looking for someone for years and
years and all of a sudden you know they
found this person. So, it's I
ideally have these conversations prior
to getting married or have You can, but
you just put let's put ourselves in the
shoes of a sister who's 34 years old.
And obviously we have the stigma as well
with that which they shouldn't then we
have the the reality of our biology
again with like for example when it was
Ibrahim alayhis salaam Ibrahim alayhis
salaam's wife where where she was like
I'm I'm barren. Exactly. For Allah
subhana wa ta'ala all things are
possible. 100%. This is our deen. This
is what our religion teaches us, yeah.
But it's just to obviously understand
the reality as well. So, keeping that in
mind now they can have a discussion
beforehand, but how she going to feel in
a power dynamic where he's 40, he can
have kids till he's 80. She she might be
thinking oh my gosh this that etc. I'm
already So, for him to say couple of
years and she's thinking it's been hard
to find someone who's a good man. Now
she's going to have to put up with that
she could she could she's going to If he
says, "Well, that's a non-negotiable for
me." She has no choice but to be like,
"Well, okay, but then Do you get what
I'm trying to say? So so
say, but
if it was non-negotiable, then that
should have been discussed prior. Cuz
you can't go into a marriage and then
all of a sudden change everything and
say, "No, um I thought about it, but
it's not right for me, so I'm going to
Yeah. a lot, not just sisters, sorry, a
lot of
You'll have the initial conversation of
when you want to have a child and stuff
like that during your marriage, right?
But people change their minds after they
get married. But one thing I want to
They do. One thing I want to say that
people like when they're more older like
in their 35 and their 40, they're more
mature
than younger people. So it it might not
even take that long for them because
when they're younger, they make their
mistakes and when you're younger, it
takes you longer to know things, know
about yourself. When you're that age,
you're kind of more mature.
So it might not even take that long for
them to kind of My friend
has that situation you're talking about
where
he's planning to get married to a girl,
right? She wanted to get have a child by
certain age. They discussed it later on.
So after they discussed all the sort of
marriage ceremonies, all of that, then
they discussed, "Oh, wait, when do you
want to have a kid by the way?" She said
age of 26, but he said, "I actually want
to have it a bit later cuz I want to
enjoy the sort of freedom and stuff."
And they end up not getting married
after that. No, but I No, I think it's
valid, though. If he thinks he's not
ready for a marriage, why should he feel
pressured into
And there is a sense of freedom. No, no,
hang on a minute, mate.
There There is a sense of freedom in not
having a child. I'm I'm not saying If
he's enjoying freedom, then he shouldn't
get married, shouldn't he? No, no, you
can have you can have freedom in a
marriage, but then some people feel
trapped when they're having a child.
There needs to be sort of
it's a blessing. That's what we need to
look at. But the man can see it as a
trap in the sense where he'll feel his
social life career will be limited to an
extent. What I'm saying is he needs to
overcome that before he decides to have
a kid.
If a man thinks like that, he's not a
real man because the thing is having a
family is is for us is our For me
personally, it's everything.
Looking after my kids is everything for
me. So if man thinks he's trapped and
he's going to lose his freedom, then he
should stay single. The thing is not not
every man is like you, that's the thing.
And alhamdulillah, like, you know,
you've got a good mentality when it
comes to having a family, but a lot of
men they don't want to feel pressured
into having a child. They want to have a
4-5 years, 3 years, whatever it may be,
then have a child afterwards. Maybe
they're not doing their career. Exactly.
Me as a 25-year-old, I would not want to
have a kid at at this age cuz mentally I
wouldn't be able to do it. I've got a
social life. I've got so much stuff
going on, two free jobs. I wouldn't be
able to handle a kid cuz mentally I I
just wouldn't be prepared. So why would
I rush into having a child?
When would you want to have a child?
When would you want to have a kid? Like
let's say roughly. So I'd say let's say
if I were to get married today, yeah,
I'm 25, I'd give it like
I'd give it like Yeah, I'd give it Are
you done? Okay, cool. So
I'd give it a couple years, so I'd maybe
27. The thing is, brother, look, what I
want to say to you that
when you have kids, you think, "Oh, you
can't do anything. You've got so much
going on." Just everything works out.
With me personally, I was working so
much. I was doing three jobs day and
night on 2 hours sleep, but I still
found time for my family. So the thing
is don't like And this is the mentality
that people think that, "Oh, you can't
do this. You can't do that. I can't look
after my kids. I can't give time to my
wife." You find time. Allah gives you
that time. Allah gives you that
blessings, you know? Trying to add
something. So what if what if you've got
a situation where um a husband's become
a father and he's not fit to look after
the child?
Well, that's a different situation. He
shouldn't become a father then, should
he? But but you're saying that he should
just with Allah's blessing, he should
just do it. Allah will bless him. Thing
is, no one's ready to become a father.
But what about the people who literally
when they get married decide to have a
kid and they're horrible fathers?
Would Would Would you not Would you not
recommend it?
Like not there for the child, not there
for the for the wife. Would you not want
that man to mature first and then
eventually have a child? The thing is,
when do you mature? When do you mature?
There's no age of being mature. When you
know when you can prioritize your child
over your social life. Well, when you
have a child, you find you find
maturity. Okay, not even social life.
Prioritize your child over anything else
cuz that is the most important thing.
Prioritize your wife and your child. I
think what he's saying I I think I can
agree with both you guys in the sense
where what he's saying there responsible
men out there. And let's be honest,
there are a lot of irresponsible men out
there, yeah? For men having a child is
just to them it's just an intimacy. It's
just like, "Okay, yeah." So there is a
lot of irresponsible men out there. And
like I said, these kind of men
Well, again, we're blaming the system a
bit here in the sense as well as well as
well as long as there's irresponsible
men,
why do you even pick this kind of man?
Let's be honest in this aspect. Sadly,
sisters make some choices that they
shouldn't, you know, "Oh, he's a he's a
bad boy." Yeah, okay, then deal with the
bad comes with it.
So the thing is real men, like you said
before, at the sense where we're giving
exception to the rule with your friend.
For example, there might be specific
reasons why he's delaying it. But
generally, a man who is getting married
and does not want to have kids for a
good 2 years like we said. We said
2 2 2 and 1/2 years is very reasonable,
yeah? Especially if you guys are really
young, I would even say 3 years. If
you're young and you're like 20s, etc.,
no problem.
Take your time.
However, what I was
However, if you are going to get married
and in your head you're like, "I don't
want to have kids for 5 years," this
man, I would say alarm bells. Like
why do you not want to What priorities
do you have? And a lot of the times
which I've noticed in married couples as
well, the problem is greater in the head
than it actually is. I've noticed so
many times where couples have issues,
problems
of a specific matter. But you know what,
like it goes back to tawhid. Everything,
by the way, all our problems in this
dunya goes back to our lack of tawhid.
You have an issue in your head and the
problem is bigger in your head. The
reality you have in your head is not
even
the reality that's happening. And then
when Allah subhana wa ta'ala says,
"Look, this" I like giving examples in
my own marriage, okay?
A specific issue that we had with me and
my wife and it was like, "Look, you
know, um and my wife was like, "No, no,
no, this time." I was like, "Look, just
let's wait and see." Yeah? And you know
how a woman can be emotional, and you
need to understand them. And I was like,
"Look, it's not how you think it would
be." And then when it came to be
and it did happen and I gave her that
look. She's there. I just gave her that
look and I was like,
"Yeah?" And why? Because sometimes we
make problems and it happens with me
sometimes. I exaggerate something. And
then I'll be like, "Actually, you know,
she she had a point there." Because our
problems in our head is bigger. But what
the issue is when I say it's a lack of
tawhid is Allah had other plans. Like
you said, when you got married, Allah
made a way for you to have time for your
kids. When you have trust in Allah, what
you have in your head is sometimes from
shaytan. "Oh, no, this is going to
happen. How do you look after You know
when you're giving in charity, this
happens a lot. "Oh, you're going to be
poor. Oh, but you you're going to lose
money. You can use that money somewhere
else." But But the sadaqah never make
you poor. Never. So it is we take the
trust of what Allah and His messenger
said over our limited understanding. So
that's why sometimes don't make the
problem as big in your head than it is.
And a man, I believe, who is going to
wait 4-5 years to not have kids and he's
got other priorities in place like
I don't know, I want to go to with the
friends or whatever, this is a man there
should be alarm bells to you.
for 1.3
Um this is a very important point and
that if you've been married for year and
the sister can't see having kids with
this
the man or the man can't see having kids
with this woman, this is a big thing
that we need to keep an eye because the
thing is like with me personally when my
when met my wife, start knowing her,
that was the only woman that I could see
having a family with.
Yeah? So this is a big thing that she
needs to be the right person to have
kids with. I mean, people change in
that, but still be safe about it, you
know? Trying to be the best safe. Don't
just go in with a blind, cover your eyes
and just walk into it because the thing
is anything could happen, but but trying
to be safe when you walk into this
situation.
put a facade on for a year and a half?
Oh, yeah. That happens a lot, to be
honest. So
As in
they're like somebody totally different
for like the first year and a half, 2
years, and then and then after giving
birth, Yeah, well, the thing is the
thing is like with birth stuff and when
a woman has birth, they can change
because a lot of men don't like when
their woman puts a child before them.
I don't know why they have a problem
with that, but a lot of
men change. We feel lonely. I don't
The thing is
the thing is my kids come first. If my
wife put my kids first and
and she knows I put her my kids first
before
if you're being neglected? I know men
who've come to me and said, "Bro, I feel
like a ghost in the house. Like I my
existence is not there. Like kids, this,
this, this." And then after this me and
my wife was
Me and my wife was at shopping and she's
like, "And did you get this for
my daughter and this one?" And I'm
looking at her. I'm like, "What about
the the other baby?"
So I was like, "What about the other
baby?" Yeah, but I do that with my I
mean, I'm like showing more attention to
the kids and they're like, "Yeah, yeah,
whatever." It's It's It's normal. It's
the mother nature. It's the mother
instinct, which you're a midwife, you
would know. So you can educate us a bit
more.
to say like some mothers, honestly, it's
a mental struggle for them. They feel
like they're not good enough. They feel
like they have to keep like, you know,
they fed their kid three times a day,
but they still feel like the kid's not
gaining weight. They have all these
problems on their head a man does not
have. And so, you know, have mercy when
you see your wife and you're thinking
she's leaving me alone, you know, I'm a
ghost in my own home. You know, just
have mercy with her and just try and
understand, try and have empathy.
Empathy means like
you know, not putting yourself in her
shoes, but trying to understand every
action and where she's coming from and
every emotion she could possibly be
feeling.
leads onto another topic, actually, to
be honest, because the man realizes that
he's a ghost and she's doing it just for
the kids, but so he doesn't want to be a
burden on her. He'll go to someone else.
That's what ends up happening,
unfortunately.
you a case study?
So, you know, I knew a family where
the wife died.
May Allah, you know, grant her jannah.
And you know, she had an autistic son
and three kids. So, that's four in
total. And so, the husband, he was in
kicks. So, the you know, she had the
baby and then she died. So, the baby was
still a baby.
And you know, as the baby was he went up
all the way to 4 years old and
undiagnosed autism. And that's because
the father had no idea what to do. He
had no idea who to go to and he just
continuously watched that child grow up
with so many difficulties including
non-verbal
autism. So, that's you know, pretty high
on the spectrum for you to be able to
notice it. And you know, the child
wasn't eating right. He had you know,
very incredibly bad diet. And so, you
know, these kind of situations just
makes you think like
a woman will have so many things on her
mind. She could not possibly watch that
child grow you know, and and not help
the child in
making sure they get a diagnosis, making
sure they get the proper help and making
sure that you know, his feeding and his
diet becomes better. And that's because
you know,
I think we have a lot more things going
on in our minds in terms of the child's
care than the father does. And the
father would you know, this in this case
the father you know, just put his hands
up and started passing the child around
to different families instead of
actually taking the responsibility and
and making those steps. And that's you
know, did you know, But he's a sister,
he's a father, he's a provider. Like if
you think about me, you might be in that
sense where he has to go out and
provide. And this is where we need This
is why it's so important we we complete
each other as men and women. So, it is
it is. And I'll be honest like some men
are very ignorant to this stuff. That's
why it's so fundamental to have the
motherly instincts there and it's it's
it is really You have to think about
these things. You have to think about
infertility. You have to think about
your wife dying. You have to really put
yourself in these you know, in that sort
of process you know, to think
had anything bad happened, can I step
up? And you know, you really have to
question yourself and you know,
So, at what what point does it become
like the patience of a man? Like how
much patience does he need until it
becomes an issue?
Cuz
I know a lot of people who where the man
continues to feel like a ghost in his
own house. He's done everything he can
to provide, to be there for his wife and
the kids, right? And he still feels
neglected. It's been 2 3 years, maybe
even more. And the wife still not giving
him attention. There's like a big
disconnect between the two now. He's not
sure why.
Yeah. So, what can be done in that
situation?
Communicate. Communication.
Communicate from the beginning. Yeah,
like see each other.
You know, don't just look at the
situation and say woe to me and do
nothing. You know, talk to each other.
Try and find out what it is you could
do. Like maybe
get a babysitter for the kids and go out
and do something with yourselves. Like
you're still in a marriage. You're still
in a team. Like you know, be romantic.
Do things. And also, again, don't just
watch her and say woe to me. You you can
think of things to do, you know? You can
try and
help her out with the parenting. Try and
have that bonding moment whether it's
just as simple as changing a nappy and
you know, making jokes with her. You
know,
you can do so many things.
or give her a break so she can just
relax and It's making that effort I
think.
The effort you made before having
children with one another, the effort
you made if you knew one another before
marriage, don't stop that even after
having kids. I think that's very
important. And after having children
obviously all the care, your attention
goes to the kids. But even then there
should be a middle path where you both
meet. And again, it all comes down to
communication.
I think yeah, communication is a big
massive thing that we feel like our
partners are mind readers. A lot of
women think that by the way. Let's be
honest because we we are very logical.
We direct to the point. Me and you have
a problem, yeah? Either we solve it or
you kill me.
And then come to my janazah and do
salatul janazah for me.
That's how it works with men. It's very
simple to the point. We argue, we talk
about it. If it doesn't work, it just
gets physical.
With women you need to understand they
are very
they would like you to know. Yeah, it's
they do indirect etc. That's how their
nature is. You know, it's not that you
blame with that's how your nature is.
And and a man and a man needs to know.
It is anyway I I would
love to see that but that's a different
topic in itself.
No, I just want to you know, the word
the woman should know. A couple of times
brother Ali has mentioned the man's the
leader or the provider. But it's the
man's responsibility to provide a safe
environment for his wife and his
children. Exactly. Now saying that,
like you said oh so if she needs 3 years
or you know, what am I supposed to do?
But you're the man. You're the leader.
You're supposed to be leading the home.
So, this is something that a lot of men
don't understand what it means to be a
leader. Like there's a boss. You're not
the boss. You're a leader. You're
someone who
leads the family.
The man should take the lead and try and
sort it out. So, yes. So, when it comes
to you know, when it comes to okay, so
financially only. No. Exactly. 100% I
agree with you. Yes, 100%. Leader in the
sense of emotional, financial, you know,
health and mental True. True. Like like
like I'll be honest with even in my
marriage I'll be honest. I don't believe
I'm still there. Like my wife sometimes
I'm just like, you know what? I could
have dealt with that better. Like I
should know better. And I've realized as
as
with my wife as well which is sometimes
I'm like, you know what? I'm I'm I can
be a leader when it comes to protect and
provide and all that kind of stuff. But
am I a leader when it comes to emotional
intelligence?
what I'm And I'm not. And we as men have
to yes, we need to be like, you know
what? I should know better. Yes, she
said this or maybe she didn't mean it.
Like we have to know better. Okay.
So, can I just finish? So,
Sorry for you finishing for me. Okay.
No, no, no. So, when we say a leader,
it's that leader's job to go find out
information. Why is my wife behaving
this way? What is out there for me to
learn? Like we mentioned post-natal
depression, post-natal psychosis. Now
post-natal psychosis brings on symptoms
that many people think that woman is now
possessed.
Yeah, this is a big one in our This is
big one in our community. A lot of
people need to listen to this one. Yeah,
we're not we're not on we're not talking
about that subject. We should do you
know,
a topic on this. I'll have a whole topic
inshallah.
But yeah. So, a leader is someone who
leads the family. What does that mean?
Go out and gain the knowledge. She's a
young especially if you're married to a
young woman. Even if you're married to a
woman who's in her 30s, 40s, she might
not herself looked into what happens
after having a baby. Why not? We we
think about baby after 9 months you have
a baby. But what comes with that?
You know, sometimes sisters themselves
don't know these things.
don't want to be constantly negative
like but I'm just offering a different
opinion. I don't necessarily agree.
that but I'm trying to also educate
people out there. We say leader. We say
provider. We need to
Yeah, exactly. We're throwing all these
words around.
with everything you guys have said,
right?
But again, there's been situations where
even if a man is trying to take take
charge, right? What do you mean by
charge? Okay, like leadership. All the
things you just suggested. Taking sort
of charging the household, taking care
of Do you know what I mean? Being there
for the for his missus essentially. And
what if the woman still doesn't sort of
agree with that? Cuz nowadays it's very
common for
Then you need to
source Yeah.
source somebody who knows
what to do in the sense counselor,
therapist. Men men are very like it's
very hard to do that cuz there's a lot
of pride to go to a counselor or a
therapist and say, "I've got problems
with my marriage. Please help me." Can
we can we just All right, let's do this
here. Let's start talking about the
solutions that these two individuals
should discuss in those two years before
they have
get married. Yeah, I think that's Let's
let's talk about the solution which we
already are.
But one thing that I would talk about as
well is that
our sisters need to understand that the
whole point of the show is obviously to
preserve the marital union cuz there's a
direct attack on that. So, as as as men
you need to understand we are also you
guys are mentally more stronger than us.
Please understand that. We are
physically stronger. Yeah?
If brother brother Sartaj punched me, I
don't think he would ever win. But even
if he gave even if he gave like 20% of a
slap, I think a woman would die. Yeah?
No, no. It would. It's true. It's You're
physically stronger but mentally I
believe you guys are more stronger than
us. That's why if you look at suicide
rates men are more prone to commit
kill themselves. We are weaker. You need
to understand something, yeah? That's
why sometimes your words cut us up. Like
you think I just No, I was just venting
out. I don't care what you're venting
out. You said some mad stuff. Like what
you said is like me punching you. That's
how it feels to us. And this is where
because it's verbal, women get away with
it. It's like, "No, but she was just
venting out." Yeah, but if it's it's
good like Do you get what I'm trying to
say? We are weaker in that element. And
sometimes you ask the big the question.
What's worse? Physical violence or
psychological? Physical violence is
still it's it's wrong. But a bruise can
heal. But when you psychologically
destroy and dismantle an individual as
men, sometimes sisters you have to vent
out. And when they are pregnant, now
like you said some some say they're
possessed or they've got a jinn inside
them or whatever. No, they don't. But
that is a lot to deal with. That is
something where you already we've got
the responsibility of being a leader,
provider, protector. And now we're
coming home to where we deem it to be
peace. And our wife is going through
something. She's okay. She's not
blameworthy as well. But at the same
time like I don't know what example to
give. I don't want to get into that
details but it's like argument's sake a
man has a this cycle cycle whatever he
goes through and he gets physical.
They'll be like no tolerance. So, what
we're saying is as men, please
understand us.
The words are very hurtful.
Mercy on us because we might look tough.
Like I mean, if someone saw brother
Sartaj, they would do a U-turn and be
like, you know, I I don't want to really
mess with this guy. But wallahi I'll be
honest with you. Like you Muhammad Hijab
But wallahi I know brothers who are like
a tank. They're built The guy is like a
tank. But they would come I've heard
stories. They would come and they
complain about their wife, bro. I'm
like, "Bro, you're you're a tank, bro.
What are you on about?" But I understand
because I'm like he's like, "But she
said this. And how could she say that,
bro?" I'm the
The guy is you look at at this grown man
who's like a tank, he would beat up four
guys and he's crumbled. So, please
understand as men we look harsh and we
look mean and somebody tries to say
something like but we are really deep
down weak. So, I would say to sisters
that are watching this, please
understand yes we want to uh we can put
up with it by the way as long as nothing
physical and you know you're saying some
mad stuff by the way. We don't want to
give you guys like a all you can all
like a buffet, you can all all you can
eat, yeah? Um there should be tolerance.
So, where do we draw the line where you
understand as men we look strong but we
are deep down weaker uh in that sense.
Um so, can we talk about some solutions
from you guys maybe and then we'll come
to the brothers.
So, is it us guys first now? Yes,
please. Okay. So, yeah. Yes, speak to
the sisters and advise them as well,
yeah. Do you want to go first or me?
Okay, yeah. So, communication is the
key. So, a lot of the times um
us women are told that men don't care.
You know, and our culture's a big one.
Culture's a massive problem.
Culture is a big big problem in our
situation. I'm the man, you deal with
them having a child, you deal with the
house because I'm the leader, I'm I'm
going to go financially provide. And
some some men stop at that.
I'm financially providing and that's it.
So, therefore how does a woman then
connect emotion to you because you're
not showing any emotion towards her.
You're not understanding that she's
going through something or if you're
just saying yeah, I'm the provider, I
financially provide and I work. So, as a
society what are we doing to our men and
women? How we programming them? What is
programming us? If you look at it if you
look at media media's a big one where
you know women are okay, they cry all
the time but men are these you know
strong individuals no matter whether
they're built or they're not built but a
man is strong, physically strong,
mentally strong. All of this the
strength is given to the man that he's
the strong one and then women are looked
upon as weak. Now, what's happening in
our society? Women are playing the role
of men when actually we're not weak,
we're quite strong. Yeah, we're actually
yeah.
So, what's happening? Women's beliefs
yeah. So, yes we're strong in the sense
okay in some case mentally giving birth
physically we are strong. So, now if we
look at that and you know Allah has
blessed us with that, not the man.
So, now
where do where do we go down the road in
that sense that men are physically
strong, women's also strong because she
can give birth to a baby. I'm I'm
physically So, you know I think men
we're not physically strong. So, I
like we're not really
in the sense We are physically look,
I'll be honest, physically there's
there's Billy Jean, there's nothing. But
when it comes to psychologically,
mentally we are not as strong. This this
is very
I'm saying we need to
as a society we need to be educated.
So, okay, what what should couples speak
about before? So, they're going to like
okay, we're we're going to have a we
want to have a child in 2 years time.
Let's prepare for that. Let's have those
talks etc. What do you like as a midwife
uh sister and then sister and Namrata as
well? Um what what would you say a man
So, talk to a man and say what should he
prepare for with his wife? What
discussion should he have with his wife?
And also please can you educate the
sisters who are watching also as well
give them some nasiha and then we'll
come vice versa to the brothers cuz you
have some experience you have a child, I
have a child, you've had a child um and
inshallah we can help brother Matthew
Why not Matthew? Let's get him married
inshallah.
Um because I'm going to explain to you
like yeah yeah yeah
come on Matthew.
I would say first of all, you know, you
can go by society norms in terms of like
these discussions and stuff like that
but really and truly
when you're with your husband or vice
versa your wife, you're a team.
Forget the outside world, forget society
norms. You guys know each other more
than anyone else in the world. You guys
operate in your own way, in your own
team, in your own you know, um
again like
you guys both know each other's
strengths, you know each other's
weaknesses and it's not based on society
norms. So, you know when you say oh like
the woman's a lot stronger mind than the
the the man and the man's a lot stronger
in physical
you know, that's just society norms.
Take yourselves out of that. Don't be
brainwashed by what society is telling
you and just go off what you two are
vibing off each other, okay? You guys
both know each other more than um anyone
else in the world. And in terms of
advice, in terms of these discussions to
have, again
having a baby, and getting pregnant, and
the whole parenting is you know, this is
a broad like subject. There's so many
things you could discuss. But the main
things to discuss is are we prepared
financially for any sort of situation
whether that child becomes disabled and
you have to you know, take out a lot of
like um
you have to pay for a lot of medical
bills or a lot of
just in the care of a disabled child, if
your wife dies, you know, there's so
many subjects you could talk about and
just to sit down and try and cover as
much as you can. And also the midwives,
when you go to your antenatal um
you know, appointments, we do cover
these things with the women and the the
father and we do have chats with the
father as well. And so, you will have a
push towards what kind of things to
discuss. And it's upon you to use your
initiative and and just be ready, be
vigilant, be ready and and you know,
just that's the only way you could
really prepare. And also
the biggest thing is Allah, you know? Um
making dua
you know, a parent's dua that between
that and it being accepted is a piece of
cloth, you know? You guys could really
prepare yourselves in in that sense as
well. So, there's many things you could
do and just cover your backs and be
ready. That's all I could say, honestly.
And also enjoy the ride like don't be
too scared of it cuz it can be fun.
Can can be is the keyword. Yeah.
Yeah, I think there's um a lot of
educating to be done as well, a lot of
research within that whole communicate
that let's say you know, the whole 9
months. You have a lot of time to
communicate with your spouse getting to
know because you're still in the process
of getting to know her. That will never
stop. You will always get find out
something new about your spouse and
within that process I think don't just
leave it at oh you know, yeah we're
ready to have a baby, we're financially
strong. A lot of research needs to go
into it. For example, even after having
a baby for example, postnatal depression
um some women sometimes don't even come
out of that whole um situation.
Sometimes for them therapy, counseling
doesn't even work. For them sometimes
speaking to your spouse might be the
only thing that works. So, I think not
leaving the conversation as oh you know,
we I have a good job, I have this much,
I'm able to have the baby. The research
needs to go into you know, the
aftercare, the looking after the child,
the pattern, the family dynamic, how
that's going to change, your shifts and
you know, all of that stuff. Having
those conversations with your wife and
sometimes there might also be things
that she doesn't know. So, you can
educate her. There's sometimes things
you won't know. Um you know, she can
educate you. So, that way it is a
balance. It works both ways. There's a
lot of effort needed.
Should there be any conversations with
uh the wider family as well? Absolutely
not. Yeah. I think having a child is
some like for example like sister said
After you finish your Like sister said,
um it's you as a couple having a baby,
not anybody else. At the end of the day
the responsibility is for you, the
mother and the father and uh
opinions opinions and all of that that
does in a certain way matter but ideally
I think it's between the um mother and
the father and they should take
responsibility for what they want to you
know, how they want to look after their
child. Okay, good. You said absolutely
not, why sister?
Um I strongly disagree with that because
you know
as a mother if you have other people's
input especially mothers-in-law,
sometimes they are not the nicest of
people. Um as much as you know, we would
all love to have a mother-in-law who's
very welcoming and loving and even your
own mother as well. Um
welcoming other opinions, again it's the
same thing as when you're having a
dispute in your marriage, would you go
and tell your extended family? Someone
you trust, yeah. Someone you trust but
these things are not actually advised in
Islam.
Um you know, you should have your
disputes within each other and trying to
solve it out within each other before
you go out to the extended um Not not
not disputes. Uh so,
we're talking about for example,
preparing for having a child. For
example, the dynamics like in my house
um my mother-in-law and my mom also
plays a key role in like helping with
the kids. If it's blessed then
absolutely
Yeah, yeah like so if you're talking
about the toxic mother-in-law who's
trying to tell you what to do etc. She's
going to make the situation worse. 100%
understood. Uh but I think they should
have that dialogue discussion. Uh what's
my two cents piece from the little
experience that I have is I think those
discussions should be had and also like
for example, sometimes the baby always
let's say she cries all the nights uh
all times of the night uh but sometimes
if if a man is working I think it's good
to communicate with your wife and say
listen
I understand you need help and I am here
to the best of my ability but if I'm
working the shift and I'm coming I have
I will I that night I'm I will not be
there unless it's something urgent like
okay, but other than that I mean you you
get my drift cuz sometimes the the the
wife doesn't really understand or
comprehend what the man is doing cuz she
can't see. You know, he's out there
working. He comes and he's like but I'm
yeah but I'm providing for this house.
Hello, you know what you feed the baby
with? Yeah, I pay for that. So, the the
the the point is this to be clear and be
like listen, look for example, I am
free, I have a day off on this day. I'm
I'll be able to aid if the baby's like
not settling etc. But I work Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday, Friday. I
will not be able to aid you. If you
want, if it means it's really struggling
for you, either get your mom to stay the
night argument say. Those discussions
should be had cuz sometimes conflict
happens where she's like, I've been
looking I'm sleepless. Yes, I know but
I'm going work. You get it? I think that
dynamic has to be settled so she
understands look, I'm working. It's not
coming from a malicious place. I'm not
cuz it looks like okay, I'm going to
have a baby and I'm looking at him and
he's he's snoring. Yeah, so this and
because she's not in a good place, she's
thinking look what I'm doing. Sometimes
please sisters understand that man who's
snoring, he's snoring for a reason which
he's tired, he's come back from work.
Don't see that as oh, he's chilling and
I'm please cuz I've seen a lot of
marriage sometimes break down when kids
have happened. This is why I think it's
important to have in-laws good in-laws
involved because the mother would come
like my my mother-in-law would come and
stay over and I would have no problem
because as long as okay, she's aiding,
she's helping etc.
And then sometimes my mom would help
whatever she can cuz the in sha'a
dynamic is good. But if the dynamic of
the mother-in-law is bad and toxic, as a
man it's your responsibility to sadly
protect your mom's fitna from your wife
with all due respect to her and you know
what I'm trying to say. There's way to
go talk about this stuff. If you don't
talk about this, it's going to be chaos.
I think communication as you said is
fundamental bro. But yeah, I would say
that but like you said it's yeah. I
don't I don't think communication is the
main point to be honest. Understanding
is also a main aspect as well. Like I
could see people communicating all the
time and the issues but if you don't
understand what the issues are, what
good is communicating going to do?
Exactly. Yeah, so it's like the first
foundation. Understanding, finding a
resolution for it as well. That's also
just as important as communicating. You
know what I mean? I know everyone's
mentioned that but I thought that was
also Yeah.
What was the touch? Um
what I say is
the thing is a marriage is a blessing
thing for us as well
as having a child.
And the thing is the connection for the
husband and wife is very very important
because
for them to be together to bring up a
family, they need to like I say
communication and understanding is very
important and enjoy the pregnancy as
well. Like you know, be there for your
wife if she's craving anything.
You know what I mean? All sorts of
support that she needs. You're there for
her when she's pregnant, you're there
for her when she has the baby.
And and if there's a problem because a
lot of women that forget like they're so
focused on the baby because they have a
certain connection because they've been
carrying it for 9 months and maybe
breastfeeding the baby as well. They're
sometimes you kind of stay at the back
but if if it's affecting you, talk about
it. Talk about talking I think in our
our relationships and I think a lot of
Asian community, we don't talk a lot.
We like think that when everything comes
to
a bit that it it it just comes out as a
argument and then it gets worse. So if
you see a problem starting off, it's
going to be a bigger problem. Talk about
it before it becomes a bigger problem
and that I think that's a very important
The defenses are going to be up though,
aren't they? Isn't that a big problem?
What do you mean defenses going to be So
whenever you mention anything
whether you or your wife mention
something to the spouse,
their defenses go up. They're in
argument mode.
Depends how you depends how you approach
the situation. I mean the defenses are
going to be up if you argue about it but
if you talk about it, if you've got that
connection with your wife, of course
she's going to understand that you're
you're a good husband. You only look
after you, you've got your best
interest. They're not going to be
defensive. They're going to be maybe I
am like But they might be they're not in
the right state of mind as well. Again,
this is this is where I guess look, I
have to be just here is where we men
have to
we have to ride it through. It's hard.
The thing is like Islamically we have to
make excuses. You know you know what I
mean? If someone's in like even if if
someone says to me like a a stranger
says something wrong to me, I I have to
make excuses for him because he might
not be having a good day. So if you make
excuses for strangers, why can't we make
excuses for our wives? It's true. It's
true. Yeah. It is it is most most most
issues too. They're merciful because
like it's not easy thing because like
like they think about the child, the
connection with the mother and child.
They think about the child 24/7. They're
always on the mind like it is is for us
we go yeah like we have connection with
a child but we don't have it as a as a
mother has. You know I'm being brought
up by a single mom and I know how she
was with us and I see with my wife. So
the thing is the connection with the
mother is a totally different thing that
man will never understand. That's why
she's the mother and you're the father.
Politely
interrupt there. Um
in a medical sense, there's this pheno
like phenom I can't say
phenomenon That's the one.
Thank you.
Um there's this thing that we um say
mothers know best and that goes deep
into even knowing when there's a
like a internal health issue with your
child. It could be something very small
as a slight temperature change and the
mother could feel it. She will know and
it's something that scientists haven't
been able to put their finger on it but
as nurses, as midwives, as doctors,
everyone on the labor labor ward knows
mother knows best. When she says
something in terms of I'm not really
sure if we can go home. I'm not sure my
child is ready to go. She will know, she
will feel it. Hence why again with that
like you know, the autistic child that I
was telling you about, the mother will
know these things from
like from the baby from the newborn
stage and um she would be able to pick
it up. And so again it goes back to
bringing other people's opinions into
it. When your wife is telling you
something about your child and she's and
she's going against the people who are
giving you advice, I would say listen to
her
three times first and then listen to
other people.
She is not she's not just you know,
saying it out of nowhere. She is feeling
this. And another thing I want to say,
don't be a lazy father. Be a proper
hands-on father because I see loads of
lazy fathers. You can't be a lazy
father. Spend time with your kids. It's
very very important because the thing is
your kids will see that. If your
daughter sees that, she'll be looking
for a husband like you. If your son sees
that, she would want to be a husband
like you. So this is a very important
thing because the cycle continues. Yeah,
it's true. It's true. There is you're
talking about a specific community that
might have that but generally if there
are men who work really damn hard
and yeah, I know you're not talking
about them but yes, if you don't see
your dad in the house a lot, maybe it's
cuz he's working unless he's you know
one of these fathers. But the thing is
brother, what I've seen myself Yeah,
you're talking about extremes. That's
what I'm But the thing is what I've seen
myself in that, if I'm not there with my
kids when they were young, if I wasn't
not there like sometimes I used to go
like competitions and stuff. I wasn't
there for like few days, my kids will
act up. Yes. So the thing is the balance
wasn't there.
It is very very important and I've seen
it with my own eyes. Yeah, no it's it's
vital. They say studies show that a man
does a better job bringing kids up than
a mother in the sense let me do some
clarification for example before I get
it's it's cuz cuz cuz cuz cuz cuz the
reason being is
what the studies found is the following.
The reason being is cuz a mother is
coming with love, nature, mercy,
protection. We men Well, I would I would
agree with you there.
men you know cuz with us and this is why
because if you think about it, when a
mother becomes a single mother, she has
to have
she has to have certain attributes which
are
belong to a man because she needs to be
a mother and father. In that sense, why
that shows that that shows that for
survival you need these traits that a
man has that you can't give and that's
what I've seen many by the way in my
family.
I know individuals, extended family
where the son is absolutely destroyed
and I've seen it. I've literally seen
with my own eyes. Why? Cuz the mother
give him a job here. No, he can't do
that. No, he can't do this. Why? Cuz
she's coming from an act of mercy.
The father will say what? Get out of
here man. Go get you out of the house
you got you got two days or we don't pay
the bill, bounce. Yeah? And he's
thinking Do you get it? That is the
missing component and I've seen many men
destroyed by
Again, understand. We're not saying this
is the mother's fault cuz sometimes it'd
be dad that leaves. But what we're
saying is the vital element of the
father being in the life is so key and
crucial. We need to wrap up but any last
words? Yes, I do have last
First of all, welcome sister for
mentioning, you know, Yeah. certain
laws.
This is very vital. Yeah. Yeah.
Um the other thing was a brother
mentioned
earlier on in the discussion about you
know, if the woman she doesn't I don't
know what it was if she's not paying
attention or she's concentrating on the
baby and she's ghosting the husband,
then he might go out and find you know,
something else and it happens. Now
that's a very immature man.
You know, he's he's not a man. I would
say he's still a boy.
He doesn't understand that you know, you
can't just just you've put that woman in
that situation. You've decided to have a
child with that woman. Then you can't
just jump off the bandwagon and say
okay, now I can't deal with this. So
therefore now I need to go
find so now tell me one thing. When that
man goes off with that other woman, is
he not going to have a child with her?
Isn't the same
cycle happening again? How's he going to
handle that? That's that's why a lot of
them will go to escorts for example
or even on the internet. Okay. That's
not what I'm talking about.
Okay, so let's just bring some clarity.
I think what you're trying to say is
that when they're intimately being
neglected.
Yeah. Okay, that's this is a reality.
Obviously there's a balance that has to
be taken. But just to put context to
what he's saying is obviously I'm I'm
sure you're not saying that any man that
you know, his wife is and then he's like
no, I'm going to get well, you're going
to go to the same problem, you know?
It's like I tell sisters you know, if
you're if you think you know, you're
going to run away from the issue of
polygamy, the next man is the same
problem going to come in a different
form. The problem is this.
Men with us when it comes to intimacy,
the way with there's many studies that
show this. There's a hadith, the Quran,
Sunnah, the prophet peace be upon him
told us the biggest fitna for a man is a
woman. It is out there. Do you get what
I'm trying to say? When a man calls his
wife to bed and she says no, the angels
curse her. The hadith does not say go
and force yourself upon her. He says
rather, "Okay, no problem." Because
she's actually um um
using that against him in that sense
because she's weaponizing. If you think
about it, the Hadith is actually the
vice versa in that sense. So, for us
it's such a great thing and men are
neglected um because if you think about
it, there's
um obviously we're adults here and we're
trying to have a discussion that it can
benefit you guys at home. But when a
woman is pregnant, it is hard it might
be hard to have intimacy and then after
that she gives birth, then there's the
postnatal bleeding and then there's uh
the postnatal depression. For us men,
you need to understand let's be real
here. One thing that I've actually sunk
in for me here besides
talking is we men as long as men as well
as our sisters as well, we go through a
dam of a hell lot as well in this aspect
because it seems like it's just the
sisters who are giving birth. Yes, 100%
but if you think about it, we are being
told
she's going to be unstable emotionally.
That's not her fault. We need to put up
with it. She's going to say some hurt
things that's going to slice you up like
chicken. You need to put up with it. On
top of that, we're going to be neglected
intimately which is the and for us it's
like and the fitna that we live in
because imagine you're not being
intimate with your wife and now you're
going out like the prophet peace be upon
him said, "If you see something outside
that triggers your
like desires, come to your wife." Now
the wife is not available it's not her
fault. However, if it is her fault, then
for a man that's a whole different
discussion but I think here we realize
we both are going through some deep
stuff and we need to really ride this
out. Yes, it's a hard time. So, um first
of all the word "put with it". Nobody's
telling anybody to put up with anything.
No, no, no.
What we're saying is
tolerate. If you want to be a leader of
the family home, then you need to lead.
You need to Okay and as women as women,
we need to be educated on how emotional
a man is, what's making him sensitive.
For example, I've come across sisters
where they thought they've not said much
but the husband's now gone off on one.
You've hurt my feelings. I didn't like
what you said. Okay, tell me what it was
that I said. Now he doesn't know how to
tell this wife what she said that hurt
his feelings. So now you have to as men
open up. So nobody's saying to you put
up with me being this way. Put up with
the fact that I've just had a child. Put
up with the fact that I'm feeding that
child or looking after that child. But
it's
down to communication again.
Understanding and accountability. Men
aren't always good at communicating and
that's the problem. They bottle their
emotions up quite a bit, don't they? So
in that situation you've given, he went
on a mad one cuz he didn't know how to
talk about his emotions. He's probably
not used to doing that.
Yeah, you're right but then you need to
know each other's you know, strengths
and Yeah, exactly. Yeah. If if he's sad
for a day or his emotions drop in like a
in in the day, you will be able to
notice these things. If you're that
closely connected and inshallah I hope
every marriage is like this but you
should be able to be so connected that
you can recognize each other's emotions.
You can recognize when one is feeling,
you know, down or when one is not in a
good situation or if they're, you know,
feeling some type of way and you should
be able to nurture each other and care
for each other and fix these issues and
communicate them.
A lot of communication is nonverbal, you
know? He he could be huffing and puffing
around. You you could be like this.
What um what I want to say is like may
the one of us ask you like, you know, if
you had a best friend that you're close
to all the time and one morning you see
him is feeling down, he's not being
himself, you ask him what's going on
because you picked up on his body
language. He's not being himself. So you
and your wife need to be like that. You
need to be best friends and like
understand each other and understand
each other's body language. Like uh the
thing is like my wife picks up on my
moods and I if I'm feeling down or maybe
hungry or or angry. hungry or angry.
Yeah, so the thing is she picks up on my
mood straight away and the thing is like
if she knows if you have a argument, she
don't answer me back because it makes
the situation even worse. Till I calm
down, she'll come talk to me.
Uh and like one thing she she told me
about don't sleep on an argument.
And the thing is that she she told me
that. So the thing is she said when you
have a argument, don't sleep on it. Sort
it out before. So these things that you
you work together on it that is a very
very important that we should do always
do this before the kids. When you have
the kids, your relationship is going to
be strong. Okay, so I need to wrap up
guys inshallah. Just a few notes from
myself and with the little experience
that I have is number one and like I
said before have a two-year gap. So I'll
say, "Okay, this two-year gap is just so
we get to know each other and because
you're going to be bonding, yeah?" Okay,
make sure you're going traveling,
whatever you're doing inshallah. Get to
know each other more please rather than
just this this aesthetic material. Yeah,
we're going to go on holiday etc. Just
for the No, get to know each other. Go
to holiday with each other. When I mean
each other, I'm not saying to another
place in the house. Yeah, on holiday
visiting each other. Yes, okay. Talking
to each other is very key. When you
decide to have a child, uh I would say
to our dear husbands, our brothers
inshallah, please make sure you're
involved when it comes to picking the
clothes,
uh the buggy etc. Whatever it is for
that matter cuz when when you're when
you're involved, it it really is like,
"Okay, he's engaged. He's excited about
this as much as I am." Sometimes even
when she mentions, "By the way, I'm
pregnant." uh please make sure your
reaction is not
Alhamdulillah.
Not that there's nothing wrong with it
but you know, it's like, "Oh, okay." Are
you sure? Are you sure? Okay, I need to
I need to go to the toilet. I'll be
back. Yeah. So that's number two. Just
to touch upon this, make sure that you
are excited. Make sure she feels that
like cuz she's going to go through the,
you know, I'm going to give birth. Is he
going to love me anymore? Am I going to
be the same? Is my body going to change?
That's number one. Number two, to the
sisters, please do not compare your
husband to Yeah, but you know,
what's her name? Alicia's husband has a
Please don't. If he can afford a buggy
that is 120 pounds, say alhamdulillah.
Don't compare your husband to other
people and be like, "Oh, but he doesn't
have a Well, like it is catastrophic
because to us that is disrespect. If I'm
working, providing, going, doing all
that kind of stuff and the only thing I
can afford is a 150 pound buggy. I know
you're telling me, "But your my friend
got a 800 pound buggy." I don't give a
damn about your friend in in a a buggy,
yeah? Okay, I don't know what kind of
relation they have. So that's number
two. Number two. Number three, speak to
your in-laws. So get the dynamics. For
example, me and my wife she said usually
in our culture it's, you know, you stay
in the mother-in-law's house and I said,
"You know, obviously like I would want
you next to me but if that's meant to
be, you know, that's fine. You know, I
can visit or your mom can come over."
Get those dynamics in place so you know
because otherwise if you don't do that,
when you're going work, she's in ahead
expecting you should help. Make sure
communication is clear. This what's
going to happen. Just so you know, I
work these days. I might not be able to
help you. Maybe your mom can come and
stay over.
Get those dynamics in place and in a
nutshell, main thing,
please make dua that Allah subhana wa
ta'ala blesses the marriage, blesses
your new child because without Allah
subhana wa ta'ala all these dynamics I
gave you is zero. When you have Allah
subhana wa ta'ala, dua, tawakkul and
then implement tying the camel and then
have your tawakkul in Allah. That's what
I would say. Did you want to say
something lastly or finish inshallah?
Yeah, just
the brother's question wasn't answered
about how do I communicate
that across to my wife. So
self-reflection is one of those things
because we all have triggers. We all you
know, there's something in us that we
believe that that person caused that
pain. So first of all, understand that
pain. Is it really something that your
wife said or is it something that's kind
of you've gone been through in the past.
Yeah, and that's come up for you. Yeah.
Now if you're struggling to communicate
with your wife, most likely there's
something that's come up for you from
the past and now you can't connect the
two. Okay. So self-reflecting and
reflecting on where that's coming from
will help you then communicate that
okay, this is what you said but it's not
about how you said it but those words
that impacted me in a negative way
because I've been there in the past or
something's happened in the past and you
made me feel like that small at that
point. She doesn't know what you've been
through in life. There's only so much
When did you say you wanted to get
you've have your first child? About 27,
28? 27, 28, yeah. About 27. Okay. And
how are you now? 25. I'm 25.
23 years Find her quickly then.
No, no, he's got a 23 years. Even if he
gets 27, he'll be 30. If he's 30, he'll
be 33. Oh, by the age of marriage plus
two years on that.
Can I can I end on one more thing?
Um please attend all the appointments,
antenatal, postnatal, labor. Just just
know what's going on. Read the books.
Read you know, yeah.
She has a book that tells her
everything, her birth plan, what's, you
know, the baby's birth percentile, it's,
you know, and all these things please
get clued up on it and know your baby
before it's born.
And um also know your wife's health
issues and the things that she's going
through as well because these antenatal
appointments will have these things
written down
and it will be spoken about in the
appointment. So please do attend. Don't
don't be deadbeat about it.
attending to when I said clothes
shopping etc. That should be a part of
it. Be involved. And again, brothers, if
you have a job which is try your best to
be there as much as possible. And
sometimes she'll be understanding,
"Look, this one I can't come to." As
long as you've come to a couple, it just
shows that you care.
Brothers and sisters, hope you guys
benefited from this. I really did.
Alhamdulillah. And may Allah bless you
guys inshallah. I hope you guys enjoyed
this episode. And like I said before, if
you if you want to be a part of it, the
email is there. You can apply.
And yeah, that's it from the Bitter
Truth Show with our honorable sisters
and our amazing brothers. Till next
time, salaam alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
The prophet sal Allah wa sallam said,
"Whoever builds a masjid for the sake of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala, Allah will
build for him a similar house in
Jannah." On that day where Allah subhana
wa ta'ala tells us that our books will
be given and every little atom weight of
good deed you've done will be there. And
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like, "What a lucky person." Which
righteous person
And Allah says, "This is for you." For
me? Yes. What did I do?
You allowed people to pray. You built a
masjid. I never had the money to build a
masjid, oh Allah. You helped. You gave
towards it, and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it. Donate
now, guys, and do not delay. And share
the video for extra rewards.